[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
let me see if i was jesus would i let
you in
oh my god dude no i mean because at the
door i'd be like bad friends
i'd be like yeah but that was just my
you know
what yeah earthly project
i know but but that was but it gave you
meaning and fun and life and i'll just
say wait go
there's a line you're going to make me
wait in this [ __ ] there's already a
line you're at the front of the line i
know i just
get up here go off to the side bobby go
off the side i got to see who else is
coming in bobby no no bobby i waited in
the line i didn't even skip the line i
could have skipped the line and said hi
to you it doesn't matter dude i'm jesus
i run the [ __ ] thing i understand but
security
all right so they put it to the side
right get off from me
but you're not going downstairs you're
making it you're not going downstairs
all right you're not watch now watch who
else i let it all right kevin specie
come on come on
we're all very spiritual in our own way
and uh i want to tell you something for
the non-believers out there
if you find spirituality in your life it
can fix you
watch
i'm not gay no more i am delivered
[Music]
so this is an old clip people on the
internet know this but it popped up on
my feed somehow again yeah i don't know
why it brought so much joy in my heart
i've never seen that before at all
really
it's the saddest video i've ever seen in
my life wait a minute george can you
there's a part where he starts dancing
do you have the rest of it or no is that
it
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh my god
oh how great oh my god all right that's
good
oh my god he was shaking out the gay
ghosts i know
shaken up
so when do you think the next time he
[ __ ] sucked the dick after that right
right after
right after anything right after that so
would you let me in i'm jesus at the
gates yeah all right you're with rudy
you guys both show up well we'd have to
have because the line is long so many
people die a day
right hold on so i'm jesus right so
and you and rooney are together we had
died in a car accident obviously right
because she was driving
yeah she was doing it yeah and well i
think if that was the case we were in
line i'd be like you know you didn't see
the red light
you guys are arguing you're the one
that's driving no you're driving she's
driving you're driving you don't want me
to drive because you always say that i
drive slow
but you were driving
fine
and that's why we got an accident
because you know you don't know the [ __ ]
you're blowing you were screaming oh i
got this jack well regardless because
we're dead now it's your fault it's your
fault hello my children
hello tito ah jules
a lovely spirit a light come in thank
you hey i'm just gonna go with her then
next
you won next
this guy
went back into the interview with his
boyfriend like
the guy that would just said that i'm
not gay no more like a year later was
like look okay obviously i'm gay
this is insane
it's so crazy here in november of 2014
in the um in the saint louis it was our
holy convocation that we have every year
i was new to the church time out okay so
push box for a second you could let me
tell you something i don't care how much
god you've got yeah you're not flipping
this guy
this guy is gay
god made this by the way god made this
human he is impossible he made him
beautiful and unique you're not flipping
this this guy is not going to [ __ ]
no [ __ ] no no he's not like uh
some other guys right now that's my
biggest problem is the idea you were
saying it the idea that you're gonna
like shake the gay out of somebody right
that's the weirdest [ __ ] who who was
insane enough to even say that and
people bought it like you can just pray
it out yeah and they this is this isn't
like
200 years ago this is like 10. this guy
is yeah on the other spectrum of gay
you're mean like if there was a pendulum
of gay yeah he's you know this is the
guy right that does the extra [ __ ] yeah
he's extra right like you come in my ass
right
spits
[Laughter]
i've done that you have with rogan i've
done that before yeah where it's like
the hotel phones like blah blah blah
blah
oh my god and i just throw [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] bag yeah yeah because i'm i
always set my alarm but you know what
the [ __ ] iphone sometimes it'll just
automatically set to p.m instead of a.m
yeah so it's set it's like oh except for
7 p.m yeah so i'm i'm woken up by it's
mr santino there's a car downstairs mr
rogan i'm like oh [ __ ] because i know
joe is like
like so anxious to go he's like where
where's the [ __ ] oh he does that he
wants to be so scared it's pretty right
on the nose with him yeah and i'm so
precise with my time yeah so with him
with that because because we had gone
out in like
i don't know cleveland or some [ __ ]
wherever the [ __ ] we were and we met up
with jessica may paluso
love her love and we were going out and
we weren't even staying late i just had
a couple of drinks and we just we hung
out we weren't even like going out we
just hung out at the club
and then of course i go back i set the
alarm wrong and he's he does this thing
in the car look at you're me you're me
when i get in the car go ahead open the
door i'm you yeah you're and i'm joe
all right we're good to go
oh that hurt what you just did there so
the whole way to the airport i was going
like this you i would do this you know
you do this you you go
those are fun shows
why do you even say anything because i
don't know what to do i shut down i
would shut down but that but then if
you're too quiet then he's like
what's going on last night and then you
have to go
out when you went to the bed
you sound like an idiot either way
you're done if you just say it's not
there it's not there yeah that's so
that's so nuts yeah my neighbor i told
you this right my neighbor went to
prairie the gay camp yeah you know what
he said to me what
he goes as a in the closet 15 year old
boy
what do you think was more heavenly for
me
going to church with my parents and
hiding it or going to a gay camp with a
bunch of repressed gay kids in the woods
alone
you sent a gay kid how excited that'd be
he was like it was he's like it was a
candy store of penis oh my god he's like
all we did was blow each other that's
all we did the whole time oh my god you
know how exciting that is he was like
why did he was like i can't believe my
mom thought that was going to like get
gay out how many counselors do they have
there to like keep an eye on them
because there's only one by the way all
the counselors are also oh no really
yeah they're also like you need they're
like religious like you need to get the
you need to get i can come tuck you in
if you need prayer with god
wow yeah he was like he's like it was
basically my parents paid for me to go
learn about sex for the first time
and they thought the whole time it's
like you're going there to get fixed or
whatever the [ __ ] they call it
it's kooky [ __ ]
because i don't know much about religion
are they more accepting of gays now or
no yeah it depends on what religion
no because i know in l.a
right they have what's that called
mosaic or yeah yeah those types are like
that new new age churches new age
christian churches they're still
christian most christians and i know gay
guys that go there yeah i'm going to
church
right and you're like what kind of
church are you going to do mosaic yeah
right and they just go well mosaic does
something except it does sound like a a
pretty game right okay so in the
beginning or in the beginning i'm like i
literally when i was fly i'll just tell
people what i'm in
yeah you don't know yeah you can tell i
can say it now
were you not allowed to at some point no
but you never really talked about it
yeah but you made it seem like you were
not supposed to no i could i just didn't
want to talk about because i didn't know
what it was and i don't know how it was
going to go so tell everybody what
you're doing all right so i i
don't like your stuff in my teeth
no great
you should spit out this gum so there's
this video game called rudy how have you
been
i really want to know
i'm good
i feel like your energy is so good today
you know also your energy grazing okay
so um
i um shout out to my boy pete downstairs
i'm not gonna talk about it shut up go
ahead all right
are you gonna do that one of those
comedy bits again
it's a comedy show
i know but there's a pretty good chance
i'm going to do it again
all right
but now i'm going to be apprehensive but
i'll try yeah and then do your bit again
here's what we always do yeah you know
i'm going to do the bit again
i know but now it's like i'm
anticipating the bit yeah so i don't
want to really fully get into the
[ __ ] don't don't anticipate it all
right here we go yeah go ahead so um
there's a video game called what's up
andreas
you did it for you i did it before you
i'm gonna do it before you did it for
you yeah stop bopping the table
and so there's a video game called um
borderlands and um they're made a movie
about it and um where'd you get your
shirt
no no
i really like that shirt no where'd you
get it she's worn that a thousand
okay all right it's the gambling the
game you know they had a gambling movie
the casino movie with amy poehler
exactly yeah
i get amped they're like they love you
they don't even need that you're they're
just gonna have this role for you as
this like um
dude that comes in pretends to be a cop
but he's really just like a [ __ ] up
looking to seal steal stuff
i go to funny or die
dude i'm so good in a room
that i'm when i have confidence that i'm
like i'm going to be fine you know what
i mean like i never go in shook i'm
never like nervous i'm always like i'm
going to be fine what the [ __ ] dude who
cares i've done a million table reads i
get in there you did a table read not an
audition no no we were reading for the
they already were giving me the part oh
so you're uh you're not a table reader
yeah because they said they didn't have
time to cast they had to shoot the movie
so they were like we're just going to
give they're like we have a roll for you
you can have it you have to come to the
read though and you have to read they go
you have to read the role and you have
to read two other roles oh my gosh don't
you hate when they do that i don't want
it yeah i don't know how to do it the
other one i don't know you show up you
show up you you worked on the lines that
you're playing i know these roles and
then when you show up you see in the
front page cop you know what i mean
passenger number one mailman and yeah
and then you go i have to read these and
then you have to do a different voice
and first take you've never done it
before you've never done it before and
there's someone in some a production
assistant comes up to you and goes we've
highlighted a couple of their characters
yeah
and you're like oh my god
so i'm like this
i'm thumbing through them trying to find
where the characters are because by the
way if you mess up the rhythm of the
room you look like an [ __ ] right so
here i am i'm going will ferrell's right
there amy's across the table um kroll is
there nick roll yeah nick's like the
only guy that i like right no no in the
room right and nick's like what's up man
i'm like hey what's up so that made me
feel comfortable yeah yeah yeah okay i
get a great guy by the way yeah love
nick i get to my line
that i know
yeah and i [ __ ] it up
and i [ __ ] it up so bad why because
because don't get nervous yes
i know you get into because will ferrell
looked over at me when i was going to
read my line
oh
no as if to say like
oh this i don't know this guy let's see
if he's funny oh no
dude i ate such a mess a massive thick
veiny penis you blush
not
can you get more red than this oh my god
yeah no i was so embarrassed dude i
literally let's just say the line and it
was quick it was there they got to be
outside behind they have to be outside
because i just climbed through the roof
it was something like that like people
were on the road now tell me how you
said it they're outside if there's a
roof
hey
everybody
just kept going like it didn't happen
because they were like jesus [ __ ]
they just kept reading yeah and nobody
looked up
nobody looked up at me no one looked up
at me to be like it's okay it's okay you
[ __ ] up no they kept going i'm getting
ptsd what do you think i did for the
other lines i [ __ ] him up
i [ __ ] up every [ __ ] line yeah yeah
i'm swear to god i'm not exaggerating
every [ __ ] line hey here's the thing
for me
and especially for the audience i'm
reading it i can't literally reading it
can't read
i can't i've been there you get so
nervous so nervous that the lines become
blurred let me do this on the way out
wait on the way out yeah this is the
face you're me and i'm will farrell yeah
ready yeah so say uh everyone goodbye
everyone says goodbye and you're me and
you say and you say uh thanks a lot just
say thanks a lot to me and you're
welcome yeah go ahead okay hey thanks a
lot
that's what he did he breathed in and
looked away and by the way
every right will is right will was right
he breathed in
and looked away as if to say
you should kill yourself you're not yeah
kill you you should have killed yourself
it's on the eighth floor jump out yeah
jump out of the window wow what are you
still alive also that same day by the
way i got to drive you don't care but i
got to drive a ferrari yeah a mclaren
and a porsche because brady matthews
brother-in-law owns a big like fleet of
beautiful cars and he let us drive him
around and i felt like a little kid in a
candy store and i it's just so it was i
felt so cool for a moment in time
driving around a rory you know i'll
never be able to afford it's half a
million dollars the car that i was i
drove a ferrari like uh four months ago
where
they le
in the opening scene of magnum pi that
oh he drives a ferrari the opening shot
is
they think it's magnum driving the
ferrari but it's bobby but it's my
character driving the phone how far did
you get to go
i spent six hours but i mean you're
driving all over hawaii but were you
driving and driving are you going yeah
yeah we would we they had cra you know i
have to follow a truck and a crane
that's what i mean right what well you
can i was ripping around but i had
rehearsals as well before i mean i did
it you did it okay do you know what kind
of ferrari it was
a red one like in the show i don't
[ __ ] know man well but there's a
specific model 2 2 9 x 360. it was a
29x360 yeah let me wait a minute the
29360i or the f f
that the fast one yeah yeah the good one
29x360f look that up please look up
ferrari 29x360f but can i tell you can i
tell you something i want to see i want
to see what i was thinking about
i might so when you were bringing up joe
rogan yeah i was thinking about um
where it went wrong with him and i
what you were thinking about what like
what was the breaking point by the way
is that the two knight of 360 right
there the girl that's what i wrote what
went wrong with you that's what you
wrote yeah i wrote the girl
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]